good
[Music]
hello how are you greetings natalia laxe
lots with the most
outstanding headlines for today wednesday
august 5 president donald trump
is taking his campaign team to court in nevada
and the national committee
of republicans are suing the state over
the  vote-by-mail plans in
november legislators approved this
bill in which voters
will receive their ballot by mail
due to coronavirus the lawsuit claims
that the process eliminates the integrity of
a lesson clark county approved an
emergency order prohibiting  rental
discrimination
it is now illegal to
deny someone a rental home
because they were evicted by the pandemic the
measure also clarifies that it is illegal to
deny someone a home based on their
income
the statewide eviction order
still has  expiration date for the
first of September the police are on
the trail of a person
who attacked an old man at the door of
a store this happened in maryland and
flamingo the judge passed the old man
was heading towards the entrance of the store
when suddenly someone approached him
and hit him in the head the assailant fled
from the  scene if you have any information about
this incident call stop crime at
70 23 85 55 55 and now we move on to
the weather forecast we will have some
winds for today with temperatures
around 104 degrees however
tomorrow we will see a drop in
temperatures although we will be
above 100 degrees have a
great day cata leal salutes
ancelotti and this was his brief
informative on our side in spanish
[Music]